in 11 days time the new chancellor Rishi
sunic will deliver the budget just a few
weeks after his surprise promotion in
the cabinet reshuffle and while it will
be the first budget for mr. su knack it
will be the last for his labour opposite
number John McDonald who plans to step
back from the front bench when a new
labor leader is elected in April and
John McDonald joins us now thank you
very much for being with us before we
got onto the budget um I just came to
ask you about coronavirus I'm something
lots of a viewers we're really concerned
about we've seen the government's battle
plan the worst case scenario battle plan
out this morning do you think they're
doing enough I think we've got a follow
the chief medical officers advice I
think that the clinicians are doing a
good job as best they can there needs to
be I think more direction from the prime
minister in particular I was worried
about the delay for example in setting
up the Cobra meetings there needs to be
political leadership of this more direct
remember this is against the backdrop as
well
is we've lost 17,000 hospital beds in
the NHS as a result of austerity cuts
that's a worry so do you think HS has
prepared I think I think they're really
doing their best but in the light of the
cuts that have gone on we saw last week
the figures the critical beds which we
needed for many of these cases 80%
capacity full already so we are
suffering from well we're suffering from
ten years of austerity but I'm sure that
the clinicians the NHS staff will rise
to the challenge they always do but
we're putting them under a lot of
pressure because we've taken such
capacity out of the NHS because they
can't so you're concerned about how
prepared a health service would be I'm
concerned that they'll because of our 10
years of austerity the capacity with NHS
has been cut quite dramatically so it
will put a lot of pressure on our staff
and conditions but they'll always rise
to the challenge their commitment is
beyond anything asked of them always and
they'll do it chief medical officer I
think is given the right advice we've
got to follow it politicians need to be
on the ball and following what advice
were given okay well we're talking to
the House secretary and that hand Court
later on the program and so be putting
some of those used to him as well
another big story this weekend is the
resignation of the most senior official
in the home office who says he's going
to be suing the government for construc
to have dismissal after what he calls a
vicious and orchestrated campaign
against him by the Home Secretary do you
think pretty portal can stay on I can't
see it it's bizarre I thought I was a
civil servant before I became a
politician I was achieving that with the
Local Government Association actually
appointed by conservative and Labour
councillors I've worked to all parties
and when you get a civil servant going
public like this
it's unprecedented I can't I can't
remember a case like this so it must be
something pretty bad that that's gone on
interesting this morning from what I
hear number 10 is only said that the
Primus has confidence in these cabinet
not specifically Priti Patel so it looks
as though she's on the way out and that
I think it says something more than
about her I think it says something
about this government itself within a
couple of months he's lost his
Chancellor and now it looks as though
he's going to lose his Home Secretary as
well I think that says something about
Boris Johnson's own ability as a
management of his own government and of
course without knowing the details of
this specifics what were in the closed
doors where the government would
probably argue that you know they are
prepared to ruffle a few feathers
they're prepared to take on vested
interests and the establishment and
shake-up look I deserve a sickness I
don't mind I don't want a shake-up I
don't mind roughing a few feathers but
you don't go into abuse that's what the
allegation is here
swearing and shouting and abusing people
and bullying people you don't go into
that so there's something seriously
wrong here one of the ways that the
Prime Minister could go forward is have
an independent investigation and but
during that period you'd have to suspend
the Home Secretary whilst that went on
but it looks as though they're
withdrawing support for and by the sound
of the statement this morning if that is
the case it needs to be done quickly and
we need to move on because we're facing
well currently virus is one of the
issues but we're also creating a crisis
in our prisons are just this system of
crime on our streets as well we need a
home we need an effective home secretary
and an effective home office okay let's
talk about the budget shall we and it's
11 days away you last is at shadow
Chancellor and the government been
pretty clear that they want to turn the
spending taps on is this gonna be the
end of austerity must be welcomed no I
looked at the Institute for Fiscal
Studies report last week made it very
very clear that to reverse austerity
they need to spend well though ifs at
about fifty four billion pounds comer is
promising nothing like that they're
talking about big figures on
infrastructure which is largely
supportable because that's labor policy
but the figures aren't good enough
there's a gap and infrastructure hole
that they've created over the last ten
years or stage about two hundred billion
pounds the most I've heard on
infrastructure he's a hundred billion
over five years that just won't make it
we've got two emergencies one is a
climate emergency an existential threat
we've got to rise the challenge of we've
also got a social emergency where
virtually all of our public services as
a result of us there you've gone into
crisis that doesn't look as though
they're going to use the scale of
investment that's needed to tackle those
problems at the same time that
government as you say are promising more
investment they're doing what you know
you've caught the end of austerity
you've called for borrowing to exist
that is what the government's rotation
so perhaps you should just step back and
force respects right a great aspect if
they were doing the right thing of
course I would this isn't party
political we're talking about the
long-term future of our country to
emergencies existential threat of
climate change and social emergency a
crisis in all our public services to
resolve those crises you've got to
invest at scale they're not talking
anywhere near the amounts that are
required and they're not tackling for
example how you pay for those services
in particular fair taxation system and
tackling tax evasion and avoidance so it
doesn't look as though they've got a
plan that really meets the challenges we
face it reports today that the
government's playing to scrap
entrepreneurs tax relief that would save
three billion pounds people would you
welcome it we said we would scrap the
relief but turn it into a grant because
then you would then get the productivity
gains that everyone needs it was a bit
again like you won't give credit where
it's true if you're saying that you
we're not supporting the relief why
don't you welcome I can't give them
credit when all they're offering us is
shops and excuses take that one example
we don't want entrepreneurs not to have
the resources that they need so instead
of giving a tax credit which is badly
directed you turn that into a grant
where you can direct the investment what
they're doing is sort of half measures
and publicity stunts that isn't gonna
that isn't but a cope with the crisis we
face a pretty extraordinary background
with such a chattered resigning
publishing his own budget yesterday in
The Times and defending sympathy for the
new Chancellor's only got 11 days not to
get everything together look I saw the
Javed's said this which I thought was
right
no self-respecting Minister would allow
himself to be treated in this way have
his staff sacked moved off the site at
gunpoint and then his staff appointed by
a policy adviser in number 10 if I was
Ricci sooner I wouldn't have taken the
job I wouldn't have taken it on those
terms you then become will you become
the deputy to Dominic Cummings that's
not good enough you dominated by number
time you need he's got an opportunity
hasn't it to pressure his budget you
could say he's a Dominic Cummings budget
that's what's going to happen he's now
going to follow the orders of a policy
adviser in number 10 no self-respecting
Chancellor now you need a strong
Treasury to make sure government stays
on course and makes wise decisions okay
now I'm keen to move on to the label
each year new of course they were
backing Rebecca long Bailey I just want
to show you a polar for Sky News this
week which shows that Kirsten was set to
win in the first round if this is right
she's just down there on 31% what's gone
wrong
what's not going wrong members a big
decision we'll see what comes out in the
final vote Kier got the most uh
nominations that's usually a reflection
of the support but we'll see there's a
few weeks to go yet and we'll see but
nothing's gone wrong the good thing
about it's like you're resigned to kiss
Tom no no I I any one of those
candidates wouldn't make a good leader
as a party that's what's great about
this this is the new jail they could all
win their own I think they could I
actually think they could I think that's
one of the best teams you'll see in our
politics for a long period of time in
terms of going into government and I
think all three of them they've made it
clear then appoint one another into the
Shadow Cabinet you'll find a really
strong team and I think that will take
us into government I think now that
Rebecca long Bailey will get a decent
Shadow Cabinet well well I'm hoping Joe
I still hope she'll win I think there's
a good chance you other we've got a long
way to go in the election campaign it's
becoming a bit interminable I have to
say it's going on for quite a bit but
but all of them I think could make good
leaders well I think you're saying that
think about what the rest of us
I just want to show you something from a
debate that I hosted on Thursday with
the three candidates and just have a
quick listen to this exchange I was
saying over again once that of course in
human rights commission is looking at us
don't close the books give them access
to all about Rebecca llambelis speak out
as Shadow Cabinet look Rebecca didn't
speak out in the same way as I did in my
view that's case tom is saying that
Rebecca long bay leaf in his view did
not speak he said no get care ride what
he said in the same way he did yeah he
did she did I was there they all kidded
so did Becky they both did so why is he
looking so uncomfortable saying that in
his view she did not speak out in the
same way that he did I don't know I
don't know because actually they both
did they have different styles of course
they do
but they both did and they both
expressed well say he's wrong then no no
I think they both in their own stars did
so he said in the way he did she spoke
in a different way of course that's her
own style but they both had way well
they both echoed what I said from quite
a long time ago which is that we weren't
fast enough in dealing with this issue
and we weren't ruthless enough both of
them echoed that sentiment okay and any
worries that if cast armor wins what she
looks like he is on course to do and
Angela Reina the front-runner in the
deputy leadership does the Labour Party
is going to move away from the Corbin
McDonald project no care issued a policy
program two weeks ago which was the
reflection of the existing manifesto
which was fine all of the candidates
there's been some individual Chris or
individual policies fair enough but you
can't you can't agree on everything but
all of them all three of them have
actually endorsed the overall political
analysis that we had what you described
him as a korbinite them well Kira said
he doesn't get designated by an
individual name and Becky and either
said the same thing I think we get away
from personalities it's the totally Ben
thing I'm into policies not
personalities okay now you and just
finally you and Jeremy Corbyn spent many
years on
you then became shadow chancellor he
became the leader of the Opposition you
had cracks at winning an election two
terms and you didn't yeah okay pretty
close in 17 then brexit overtook us and
it was like a tsunami hitting us
politically and it was I've said before
we were in a vise what if we went one
way we'd lose vote so we went the other
way in the first do you have any regrets
though oh yeah of course I did I think I
think sometimes about sorted out the
narrative from 17 that way up until 17
it was easy end austerity after that we
never really had a clear narrative and I
should have been firm about that and
I've taken the bailout so two days after
that so if anyone's to blame blame me
take it on the chin and move on and that
allows the new leadership to come in
then and have well I think their own
approach but based upon the political
analysis and largely the program that
we've developed as well we're a United
Party and that's the way which will win
the next election okay John McDonnell
thank you very much